so good morning this is Rosario zaka
from January gonna grip and partners I
am an Italian attorny I'm attending this
world economic forum because we have a
special dedicated desk to India from our
Italian law firm we believe that there
would be growing opportunities between
India and easily in the future we have
already worked on some of the major
transaction that took place between our
two countries India is already a
developed country is ready a country
that has expressed their interest in
going abroad outside of India and
purchasing companies and we believe that
Italy would be a good opportunity for
them to explore in certain sectors we
see a lot of similarities we really like
the way of Indian business to organize
their companies and we believe that a
number of companies in Italy will be
very interested in doing joint venture
contractual agreement of even selling
their business to Indian companies so
good luck photo for the future of this
country which is already emerged which
is already developed and we really
believed to be good and best partners in
the future thank you